بتعليق المشانق في جمهوريه الخوف يسع نظام
الايراني لاسكات صوت الشارع المطالب
برحيله بحسب خبراء
النظام هو في ظل ازمته التي توصف بالاسوا
اصبح شغله الشاغل اخماد الاحتجاجات
ولتحقيق الهدف عدا لا تكتيكاته القمعيه
التي لجا اليها لاخضع احتجاجات سابقه
التوقعات تشير الى ان الظلمه والعنف
الدموي سيقابل بالعنف المضاد وستجبر
المعارضه على العمل السري فاحكام الاعدام
واساليب الترهيب تحييما شهدته المناطق
العربيه والكرديه ومناطق البلوش في ايران
من مقاومه المسلحه سريه وعلانيه تم خوضها
على فترات مع اجهزه النظام في ثمانينات
القرن الماضي الى الالفيات الثانيه
الناس اما في السجن او التجهه للعمل السري
لانهم مصممون على ايجاد طريقه لمواصلات
النظام
رئيسي الذي يرفض بغطاء من المرشد اي حوار
مع المحتاجين الذين وصفهم بالعملاء رئيس
الذي احيا تصريحه في اذهان الايرانيين
دوره في لجنه الموت التي علقت المشانق
لالاف المعتقلنا الايرانيين في الثمانينات
تجمع المعارضه ذكر وبحسب موقع تصوير 1500
انه وفي رساله تحذير للنظام ردد المحتجون
شعار ساقتل من يقتل اخي كما تشير تقارير
داخل يا مسربه الى انه ربما تم اعتقال ما
يصل الى 115 عنصرا عسكريا لدعمهم
الاحتجاجات مع اشاره تقارير محليه الى رفض
المتظاهرين سياسه النظام التي يصفونها
بغير المتوازنه لاعطائها الافضل للنفوذ
الخارجيه على حساب منشره مركز الاحصاء
الايراني لان الايرانيين المعرضين لخطر
الفقر المدقع قد ارتفعت الى 50%
حنان المصري العربيه